now to a cbs news investigation of the
country's largest online mental health
provider cerebral offers prescriptions
in therapy for conditions like adhd and
depression it started just two years ago
and grew rapidly during the pandemic now
the justice department is looking at
cerebral's prescribing practices in an
exclusive interview ceo dr david moe
told our consumer investigative
correspondent anna warner that cerebral
is cooperating with the doj and he's
confident that the investigation will
find no problems former patients and
employees of the company told anna other
concerns good morning good morning nate
the ceo says cerebral has saved lives
but our investigation raises questions
about how the company treats patients
some of whom told us cerebral failed
them when they were in desperate need of
care
every single night i would go to bed
just
tomorrow i'm going to do it i'm going to
be better tomorrow 28 year old rachel
coster developed severe anxiety after
the birth of her second child and then i
wake up and
i'm home with the kids by myself and
it's just overwhelming
then earlier this year she saw ads on
social media like these stigmas and
anxieties sometimes prevent people from
seeking help they were for a company
called cerebral that offers affordable
mental health care services online
koster signed up met with her prescriber
online and got a prescription all in a
single day but after that every time i
needed her help she was never available
like when koster needed instructions
from her prescriber on how to safely
switch to the new medication they gave
her i didn't know what i was supposed to
do
she followed up again and again six days
later and still no answer koster started
the new drug then later she broke out in
a rash a potential side effect for which
the drugs maker says patients should
call their doctor right away and i
messaged back letting them know it was
spreading and getting worse
and they said that they were still
trying to get a hold of that prescriber
she finally went to the emergency room
where doctors treated her with iv
steroids and told her to stop taking the
medication she then canceled her
cerebral membership they make it seem
like they want to help and then they get
you
and they're gone
koster is one of over a dozen patients
who told cbs news they had problems with
cerebral's quality of care dr david moe
is cerebral's former chief medical
officer and new ceo he says their system
works if you look at our outcomes and
this is what's most important do the
patients get better
they do they absolutely do
but documents obtained by cbs news show
cerebral leadership was informed about
risks the company was facing including
patient and clinical safety issues hires
who may not meet our hiring standards
and staff practicing with expired or
suspended licenses
many customers complain that they like
koster couldn't reach their prescribers
to which dr mo responds the average wait
time to get to a prescriber is days and
that's i think what matters the most yet
this internal log we obtain shows the
company's own staffers flagged nearly
1200 instances of prescribers being
unresponsive over the past 11 months
wouldn't it be dangerous if patients
cannot get hold of their prescribers and
therefore can't get their medications or
they're not using them correctly
so i will say we'll definitely take a
look into this and very we're very
serious about continuous improvement
here
but it's not just patients complaining
it's like a fast food restaurant get as
many people in as fast as you can
melissa butoric worked as a client coach
for cerebral a particular area of
concern for her suicidal patients do you
feel like clients who come to cerebral
who are suicidal are in safe hands no
without a doubt now for example she
points to the company's handling of
suicidal clients through the messaging
app called slack dr mo says the system
allows staff to quickly respond to
suicidal patients within minutes a
crisis specialist would help triage this
patient to the most appropriate
level of care but one staffer messaged
about not getting a response from the
crisis team another wrote that a
suicidal patient had written into chat
last week and no one had written back
it's chaotic it's confusing it could be
extremely dangerous right if you
somebody misses the message or doesn't
follow it the words she said were
exactly hey i'm i'm going to kill myself
this former cerebral phone coordinator
who didn't want to show his face because
he fears reprisal told us he handled
calls from suicidal patients despite
having minimal training i'm not trained
i don't want to say the wrong thing and
i didn't want that on my conscience let
alone anybody to die because of
something i said wrong
i would have to review this case what i
will say is this we've invested a lot of
resources and for the most part as you
can tell by our aggregate numbers we're
able to save lives you have to take this
in aggregate and uh where many of our
patients do really well if you look at
our ratings but these people aren't
living in aggregate right you're talking
about individual lives
here
i would hope that
so
i refer
my close friends my family members to
use cerebral our commitment here is the
quality of care and now that i'm ceo
we're going to double down and triple
down on that thesis
now after our interview referring to the
internal logging of prescription issues
cerebral told us that shows the safety
checks and balances the company has in
place the company also says that it has
reduced suicidal thinking in 50 of
patients that it's studied in their own
study also after our interview the
company apologized to rachel koster
saying its clinician did not follow
their procedures and is no longer
working with cerebral and if you have a
mental health story to share with us
please send me an email werner a at
cbsnews.com last name first initial but
that some of the concerns we're hearing
from patients former employees former
clintons you know i give the ceo though
credit for speaking to you because a lot
of people in this situation are doing
the jujitsu move and you know turning
into teenage mutant ninja turtles not
wanting to talk to you so the fact that
he did sit down with you i give him a
lot but there's still so many questions
there are some flaws yes
yeah they're troubling though they've
said there are some issues that they are
working on um he has said very clearly
that he is dedicated to working on them
and that he prioritizes quality of care
above all else well he has work to do
terrific work and great stories thank
you
thank you very much